[Music]
today for our daily cancellation
we must revisit the body positivity
movement or the fat acceptance movement
or the fat liberation movement there are
many different
names for this movement all sorts of
movements are associated with the
celebration of fatness which is ironic
seeing as how
a lack of movement is exactly what leads
to fatness in the first place but
we begin with the trials and
tribulations of fat people when they are
traveling
a viral tick-tock video featuring a
teacher by the name of mary frances
donnelly purports to show the sort of
discrimination that obese individuals
encounter simply by checking into a
hotel room
this is apparently a whole series of
videos but we'll watch just one
to get the idea here it is welcome to
our hotel's fat food
with me your host your president fat
merry friend
come hither let's take a look at the
bottom as one might see
it looks normal would you like to take a
pee or a poop
don't worry you'll barely fit
[Music]
don't worry
go outside
so she appears to have a good sense of
humor about things in that video which
is nice
uh a nice change of pace from the the
sort of hectoring scold
tone that you get for most tic-tock
videos of this sort but a report
from abc news explains that this is no
laughing matter
they interviewed donnelly about her
traveling as a fat person series and
this is how she explained it quote this
video is my way of highlighting a very
real stress
i felt for years and have only recently
begun to unpack as i have looked at my
existence as a fat slash
plus size person in this world the
article then continues
while the tone of the videos is light
these things can affect how travelers
move within that space
donnelly isn't alone the comment section
on our video are flooded with people
in solidarity offering up similar
experiences quote i travel with my own
bath sheet and pool towel to avoid the
tiny towel debacle shown in the tick
tock video
annette richmond founder of fat girls
traveling told gma
quote i have to become a travel
detective while booking accommodations
investigating the hotel chairs and bed
frames
avoiding plastic chairs chairs with arms
and metal bed frames at all costs
because they can buckle under pressure
um the message this sends the plus side
travelers donnelly said is that a
vacation can't truly be a vacation
travelers either have to deal with
humiliation or prime a trip with hours
of research into what a room's
sizing and amenities may look like she
said quote simple things like a towel
size or whether a chair is stable enough
to hold a person's weight is completely
disregarded
and chalked up to the traveler's issue
she said quote it furthers the narrative
that larger bodied people are expected
to roll with the punches and
accept this sort of treatment because
since the dawn of diet culture
we've made we've been made to feel like
we're the problem
okay well i'm not sure if there's any
delicate way to put this but if you find
that you need to research ahead of time
what sort of furniture will be in your
hotel room for fear that it won't
support your weight then yes ma'am
you are the problem or rather we should
say
you have the problem the problem is that
you carry so much weight on your body
that an
average piece of furniture cannot
sustain it whose problem is that
if not yours i mean who has introduced
that problem
into the equation who's really at fault
apparently the hotel is at fault for not
making their chairs out of i don't know
concrete
we can find a similar theme in another
article published this week
this one from the website fast company
about the changes your workplace should
make in order to better accommodate the
fattest among us
it gives a number of helpful tips like
suggesting that any office wellness
programs should be quote weight neutral
in other words you should redefine
wellness to include morbid obesity and
heart disease
in other words you should redefine
wellness to include unwellness
of course we're warned that any office
swag like t-shirt should come in large
enough sizes that it could potentially
double as a bed sheet
and then it says this about the
furniture quote
companies that are serious about size
inclusion should look at their
facilities and workspaces
says peggy howell vice chairman and
public relations director of the
national association
to advance fat acceptance think about
including seats without arms or a
combination of typical chairs and bench
seating
to accommodate larger bodies the
organization has a
has created an hr guide and defines a
size friendly chair
as one with a seat size of 22.25
inches and a back size of 23 inches
width
and 23 inches height chair seats should
be height adjustable and should
accommodate at least
450 pounds
at least 450 pounds think about that
just for reference andre the giant was
only 70 pounds heavier than that at 520
pounds
but he was well over seven feet tall
aaron gibson was an offensive lineman
and one of the heaviest men to ever play
in the nfl
he was six foot six and clocked in at
around 410 pounds
most nfl linemen weigh 300 pounds less
than that so to be clear
the national association for fatigue
says that in order to be truly fat
accepting
you must specifically accommodate people
who are who are heavier
than the heaviest nfl player to ever
play the game
and i don't mean to belabor the point
here okay but
the tallest man in recorded history was
a guy named robert wadlow
he was almost nine feet tall he reached
i think was 811 is what he is what he
reached by the time of his death
nine feet tall and he weighed 440 pounds
okay the people who weigh 440
pounds today are not nine feet tall many
of them aren't even six feet tall
so my point here is just that 450 pounds
is very very very overweight
i think in order by the cdc's bmi
calculation
in order for 450 to be to be a normal or
healthy weight
you would have to be like nine and a
half feet tall
so when the uh when the fat acceptance
movement
calls for fat acceptance they aren't
simply saying that we should get rid of
the beauty standards which demand that
women
all have the weight and physique of an
upside down mop you know most of us
agree
that rail thin should not be the
standard and it isn't the standard
anymore
and hasn't been for a while i mean
everyone agrees on that
but fat acceptance goes way beyond that
they're calling for acceptance of
extreme
morbid dangerous fatal obesity
the type that requires a lifestyle of
chronic gluttony and laziness to achieve
yeah there are there are thyroid
conditions there are you know people
have different
body types and all of that people have
different metabolisms i get all of that
but that doesn't explain 450 pounds that
doesn't explain
morbid obesity
and for that reason fat acceptance is an
evil despicable
anti-human movement it's not different
it's no different from anorexia
acceptance
or bulimia acceptance it's just on the
opposite end of the spectrum
that there is no difference morally
speaking
it is a celebration of self-destruction
either way
and there's something else too i mean
this fat acceptance stuff is a symptom
of a larger problem
pun sort of intended the problem is that
in our culture today
we're losing one of the most basic
skills one of the most fundamental
capacities for any living organism
that is the ability to adapt to our
surroundings
okay now now like any capacity this has
to be moderated
it's possible to be too adaptive to try
and blend in too much but when properly
utilized
adaptation for a human being means
simply that we are conforming ourselves
and our behavior
to the structures of reality we are
accommodating reality
now like we talked about in the opening
these days though accommodation is
supposed to go the other way around
we constantly expect that reality will
accommodate us
so we're going to be however we want to
be and whoever we want to be
and we demand that all of reality all of
society
fit in around us we walk through our
lives every day like moses standing in
front of the red sea
demanding that it part and allow us to
walk across only whereas moses
used the power of the almighty to part
to see we try to use the power of
social pressure pressure of cancer
culture of activism of government
or some combination of these to
accomplish the same end
and it works often times the entitled
whiny baby who's able to browbeat
everyone else into conforming themselves
to him
he's able to do that so that he doesn't
have to conform himself to them
they accommodate him instead of him
accommodating them
it does often work these days
it works in that immediate sense anyway
but it doesn't work in a deeper sense
it doesn't make the whiny baby happy or
fulfilled
that's why he remains a whiny baby even
after he gets what he wants
he is still miserable because he's
clinging on to his own destruction
the thing that he refuses to let go of
is the very thing
that is causing his despair
the thing that he wants everyone to
accommodate accommodate
is the thing that's destroying him he
can force everyone to pretend that these
bad parts of himself are good
but he can't actually make the bad parts
good
they're still bad they'll still destroy
him
[Music]
they will still make him unhappy because
in the end reality wins
it always does one way or another even
after all of us are gone
reality remains and for that reason
the woman in that tick tock video is
cancelled
once again it was a long journey to get
there but we get back around to the
cancellation
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content